hey doing blue and Davis oh hello
I've heard your music I've heard many
nice things about you from Jim and Jean
and from others oh you have not heard
one nice thing about me from Jean no you
don't want to go anywhere and that's why
all the same [ __ ] is gonna keep
happening to you because you want it to
who's that why yes and also because
you're an [ __ ] what you say you play
folk songs folk songs I've said you're a
musician
folk singer with a cat it's not my cat I
just didn't know what to do with it
really so bring your dick along too
I should have had you wear double
condoms well we shouldn't have done it
in the first place did you ever do it
again which is a favor to women
everywhere you should not but if you do
you should be wearing condom on condom
and then wrap it in electrical tape I'm
interested in in gigging here okay let's
do something you don't want to hear the
record like should are you here for
example play me something from inside
low index okay
you
you